there's even a little bit more that we
can learn about our energy diagram and I
like to just clean this diagram up for a
little bit second because I want to work
in this area suppose our system because
the work non-conservative is zero tells
us that the mechanical energy is
constant now we don't know how much
mechanical energy our system is that's a
constant of the system but let's just
suppose that our mechanical energy is
written like that and we'll just clean
up a little give ourselves a little
space so here's the mechanical energy of
the system and that's a constant and now
we can talk about two more special
points a point over here and at this
point let's just think about what our
mechanical energy tells us this is a
special point but let's begin with one
right here if our particle is at this
location then this represents the
potential energy and the difference
between the energy and the potential
energy is the kinetic energy so this
here represents the kinetic energy and
now we can ask ourselves what would
happen to the energies as our particle
is moving so if we start right here the
kinetic energy is zero because all the
potential energy all the energy is
potential and as a particle starts to
move let's say has a little bit of
energy it starts to move in this
direction then the kinetic energy starts
to increase until we get to this point
where the kinetic energy is maximum at
the stable equilibrium point where the
forces
now the kinetic energy decreases because
remember it's now going against the
force this side the force was pointing
in that direction here it was in the
other direction and until we finally get
to this point where again the energy of
the system is equal to all potential
energy and so there is no kinetic energy
so I'll call this point a and I'll refer
to this point over here diagram is
getting a little crowded as B and those
points a and B are what we call the
turnaround points and they represent the
places where the kinetic energy at XA is
equal to the kinetic energy at xB which
is zero now the last thing that we liked
there's a lot of information as you can
see contained in these energy diagrams
and the last bit of information that
we'd like to ask ourselves is what would
happen if instead of having confining
our system to this area we increased our
mechanical energy so we're up here and
let's just follow qualitatively the
motion of a particle that begins say
over here with a little bit of kinetic
energy and potential energy and if the
particle starts off with the velocity in
the positive x-direction then it's going
to move in this direction and you can
see the kinetic energy is increasing
here we have a maximum amount of kinetic
energy but notice that over here the
particle still has some positive kinetic
energy and so it can get over this hill
and when it gets to the other side the
force was in the positive direction it
increases its connecticut
and it goes off to what we're referring
to as infinity so one analogy that
people like to make is to understand the
motion think of a marble that's rolling
down a hill and this is just a metaphor
for this potential energy function as
the marble rolls down the hill it gains
kinetic energy it loses potential energy
it comes maximum at the bottom of hill
as it goes up the hill it still has
enough kinetic energy to get over the
top of the hill and to start to come
down the other side and of course our
particle can never get to the speed of
light so it will our model has to break
off at one point